So in week two, for our mounted exercise, our goal is to have a short step and a long
step directly influenced by our breath.
So the short step, you're going to hold the air in the top of your rib cage and the long
step, we're going to show it in the bottom of our belly.
So the first candidate here is a very, very green horse and it's to show the very basic
level, even the very greenest horse can respond to this exercise well when you bring the energy
or the flow of breath into the top of your rib cage.
And then you let it flow out over your belly, he's going to take a longer step and then
back into your rib cage, he's going to take a shorter step.
So this horse is very green, he knows almost nothing about flat work, but he's still very
responsive to this exercise simply by the direction of energy through your breath.
So start there, it doesn't matter how green your horse is, doesn't matter if it goes on
the bit, whether you can or can't take a contact, you can work on this exercise very well.
Once your horse is more advanced in the connection and also able in its step, then you can really
see a bigger difference.
So here, just even at the walk, you can bring the step up and then bring the step out.
So as you push the air through down your belly out through where your belt would go, the
step is going to get larger.
And as you bring the air up into the top of your rib cage across your collarbones, you're
going to hold the energy of the step up in the air, making it shorter.
So there's lots to work on here, even in the progression of this horse's ride.
But a few things to watch out for is you can see very well in this slow mo that the direct
line from the bit to the elbow is still maintained, no matter where he puts his head to evade
the collection or evade the extension, there he gets a little pat for doing a good job
lifting his back.
So it's very important that you maintain your other positional correctiveness, even doing
this exercise.
When we go for a ride, it's important to pick one priority or potentially up to two.
But don't complicate it beyond that.
If you're going out to do this exercise, tell yourself you're going to move the horse with
your breath and do that.
Don't try to perfect every other movement.
Just try to nail down this one exercise.
So as I come up with the air in the top of my lungs, you're going to see his step come
up and shorter.
And as I let the air extend down into my belly out where my belt would go, it's going to
make the step a lot longer.
So on a horse that's a little more capable, like this one, you're going to see a physical
difference in the size of step.
So as I let the energy out over the bottom of my belly, his step becomes bigger.
And as I pull it up into the collarbones, it becomes a lot smaller.
Another thing to watch out for is that you're not pulling into the deceleration or kicking
into the acceleration.
Breathe your way there.
A few things also to maintain are straightness in the horse's body, all the vertebrates in
a line.
So you don't want much inside flexion or bend in this exercise.
Simplify it and just allow them to be straight in the exercise.
In the canter, it's the same exercise.
Bring the air up into your collarbones to make the canter smaller so that the right
front foot is landing shorter and then it's landing longer.
It's the same as the trot exercise.
There's a lot of big benefits to having this ability with your horse to move them around
with your breath.
And one of them is when you're doing a lateral movement like you just saw, you can open and
close the movement simply with your breath and the maintenance of your legs and arms
doing a lot of other things does not have to interfere with the going forward and back.
So as the horse starts to really come into the exercise and understand it, they actually
gain a lot of confidence from being able to rely on you not moving your arms and legs
into crazy different positions to try and maintain something else or to kick and pull
into acceleration and deceleration.
You're simply going to breathe there.
No matter what you're doing, no matter the pattern you're doing, you're able to do it
with harmony.